today on the matt well show this
shouldn't need to be explained but
it does apparently today we'll talk
about why christians should not
and cannot support joe biden also five
headlines including
trump receiving an endorsement from
another famous rapper and in our daily
cancellation
in light of recent events involving
jeffrey tubin i will be canceling zoom
and all other forms of video calling all
of that coming up but uh
let's we begin here you know every few
days it seems there's another
news article blog post editorial making
the rounds
uh on facebook and and stuff with a
title like
you know why this evangelical minister
is voting for joe biden or
i'm an actual pro-life christian so i'm
voting for joe biden and camilla harris
or faith leaders back biden in sign that
evangelical support for trump is waning
the polls still say that trump is
leading as expected with protestants
though biden also as expected i'm afraid
has majority support among catholics
overall
people who qualify at least according to
pollsters as highly religious
still tend not to vote for democrats
but the trends are troubling support for
joe biden or
any other democrat candidate among
religious people ought to be steady at
around
zero percent but it's quite higher than
zero
and rising and that's a problem now
i'm not here to claim that a christian
has any obligation to vote for
republicans that's not the point of the
republican party
is not the official christian party and
christians have no obligation to it
i'm also not going to argue that donald
trump is a man of deep
faith or high moral character because i
don't believe he is
either of those things you know if you
happen to listen to ben shapiro show
yesterday
i agree with his take on trump and the
reasons uh
the reasons to vote for him that's not
going to be my focus though
whatever you decide to do on election
day what i can say
is that if you're a christian or any an
adherent to any other major religion for
that matter
you simply cannot vote for joe biden you
you can obviously in the sense that you
have the right to and the physical
ability to
but you can't do it justifiably or in a
way that is consistent with your
professed worldview
and the reason for that is very simple
let's leave aside any question of
personal character
you know i don't think that biden is
unassailably decent
and honest the way he's been branded but
never mind that
it comes down to what sorts of things
biden will do
the policies he supports the bills he
will happily
sign i would say that it's not possible
to be a decent man who enacts evil
policies but even if it is
what good is that alleged decency if a
man smiles while he punches you in the
face
your nose will be no less broken for it
and in the case of biden
the consequences are far worse than a
broken nose
like this 60 million children have
already been slaughtered by abortion
since roe v
wade the grotesque and ludicrous supreme
court decision that biden supports and
has pledged to defend with all his might
as a christian or simply as a person
with a functioning moral compass
there is no way to minimize 60 million
murdered babies
we are compelled to see it just as it is
unthinkable wickedness a historic hist
atrocity
an injustice of unfathomable proportions
joe biden intends to continue this
slaughter indeed to to fund it
after opposing tax funding for abortion
for many years biden recently
reversed himself and decided that
american citizens should be forced at
proverbial or maybe not so proverbial
gun point
to contribute financially to the
extermination of human beings
biden does not support any restrictions
on abortion biden believes that mothers
have a god-given
sacred right to execute their offspring
and he plans to do everything in his
power to protect that right
his running mate we should note is even
more radically infanticidal than he is
kamala harris has been given a 100
perfect score from
the pro-abortion group naral for a
reason
good reason and this is all that should
need to be said about good old decent
joe
it's all that a christian needs to hear
but there's more even so biden is an
enemy of religious liberty vowing among
other things
to reinstate obama's policy of forcing
nuns to allow
access to contraception bidens also said
that passing the orwellian and
inaccurately named
equality act would be one of the first
priorities of his presidency
this law would make both sexual
orientation and gender identity into
protected categories
under the civil rights act meaning that
a man who identifies as a woman
would now be the victim of a civil
rights abuse should this
self-identification not be respected by
say
a women's shelter that he is demanding
access to
this is not only an assault on religious
liberty as it forbids the people who run
these organizations from operating
according to their religious and moral
beliefs
but also an assault on science and basic
common sense
and decency speaking of which joe biden
very recently
endorsed the notion that an
eight-year-old boy ought to be able to
transition into a girl
now whether he really believes this
madness or not is another question the
fact remains
that he's bought into it acquiesced to
it the most
the most the most dangerous and
fantastical claims
made by the most radical elements of his
base he has acquiesced to
and pledged to govern accordingly and on
the same topic of uh
dangerous and radical elements biden is
a staunch proponent and supporter of the
racist marxist
organization black lives matter a group
that has its spare time between
fomenting race riots and
calling for the defunding of police
departments in the most crime-plagued
communities in the nation
also publicly pledged to disrupt the
nuclear family
you know this is what joe biden supports
these are the things he plans to
actually do
granted he probably won't send very many
mean tweets and his speeches will be
less
ad-libbed and probably include fewer
profanities though there's no guarantee
on that second point
but that's window dressing anyway what
should matter
most to us as christians is that even if
he's
less bombastic about it he will help to
shape america into a country that is
even more hostile to faith
even more dangerous to children even
more fundamentally opposed
to us and what we believe
he doesn't deserve our support shouldn't
receive it
so do what you like with your vote but
don't use it to undermine yourself
and the values that you supposedly hold
dear
it's really as simple as that let's get
to our five headlines
you know uh well as you know small
businesses have really been taking a
battering since
march and many you know many small
business owners most
are really feeling the effects of those
lockdowns and often pretty pretty
extreme ways
so we're excited to tell you that this
wednesday uh the daily wired god king
jeremy boring
going to be presenting alongside a team
of world renowned business leaders at
expert ownership live it's a two-day
virtual conference about leading through
crisis
conference features a lineup of speakers
uh like leadership author
john maxwell the founders of duck
commander and otterbox
the benham brothers many others who can
relate to what entrepreneurs and leaders
are going through right now
they'll share their stories they'll talk
about uh how to you know
the challenges they faced but also how
they got through and got to the other
end
and were stronger for it that's the most
important part so visit
expertownershiplive.comwalsh to register
for 197
to get a second ticket for a friend 50
off you don't want to miss jeremy you
don't want to miss this whole
experience and you've only got uh you
know you've got less than a day to get
to get signed up so go to expert
ownership live dot com
walsh reserve your spot this wednesday
for 197
and an opportunity to get a second
ticket for 50 off again it's expert
ownership live.com
all right it's been announced uh by the
debate commission that trump and biden
will have their mics muted during the
last debate this thursday
uh this thursday night they'll be
debating final debate i believe and
they're gonna have their mics muted
um not for the entire debate which
actually wouldn't
maybe be such a terrible thing but uh no
while one is speaking and giving their
two minute spiel
um the the other one's gonna have their
mics muted
now trump has protested this decision
and said that it's very unfair quote
unquote
uh and a lot of conservatives are upset
about it
because they see it as a as a you know
something that's
being done specifically targeting trump
which of course it is
and it's a and they see it as something
that's supposed to hurt trump which of
course it is but my point is that
i although it is targeted at trump i
don't think it's going to hurt him i'm
actually in favor of this i think it's
going to help trump
my biggest frustration in the last
debate was that trump would not just
shut up and let biden speak and bury
himself metaphorically speaking
with his own words we know that biden
struggles to string together
two minutes worth of coherent um
you know of two minutes worth of
coherence in general we know he
struggles to do that
just as i clearly struggle to do it too
so let let him do it
when you only give him 30 seconds to
speak he's going to sound like
he's really with it give him the full
two minutes that's good strategy
now if trump had a certain measure of
discipline and self-control then he
could just do that without the mics
being muted
but he but he doesn't so that's why it
helps to have the mics muted so i
i think in the end it's going to it's
going to help trump
um although of course
in reality it it he's right it is an
unfair decision the fact that it's
targeted to him
and also it this is not really how a
debate's supposed to work
i'm talking from a purely political
optic sort of standpoint i think it will
help trump ultimately but
it's all it does defeat the purpose that
the actual real
purpose of a debate which is you're
supposed to debate
there's supposed to be a back and forth
that's what a debate is
all this stuff these things we call
debates none of them are debates
they they don't qualify think about if
you've ever been in a real debate with
which if you're a human being you
probably have with with just another
person like in your living room
this is not how it works it isn't okay
i'll i will i will state my case for two
and a half minutes and then you could go
and then we'll go back no it's
then we'll have 30 seconds for rebuttal
and no you just you just go back and
forth and you have a conversation that's
what the debate should be but
that's never going to happen so we make
do i suppose
uh number two speaking of trump he has
uh picked up an unexpected endorsement
another rapper another famous rapper 50
cent has come out in support of trump
so maybe so you got kanye west 50 cent
maybe they maybe they'll have a collab
next in time for the election who knows
um
50 sat on instagram posted a screenshot
of biden's tax plan
showing that people in his tax bracket
will have to pay 62 percent
of their income and he had this caption
he said what the f
uh vote for trump i'm out
or first of all a lot of emojis here so
this is upsetting me
right now this is a i've already made my
point here but this is a grown
this is if you're watching this right
now on youtube
the emojis do they help enhance the
point at all
he says i'm out of new york the knicks
never win anyway and he's got a little
emoji of a guy running
yeah i get it you know you've already
told me you're leaving i understand what
leaving is i don't need it i don't need
an illustration
you know what leaving is are you sure
because i gotta i'll draw you a picture
so you no i don't need that
anyway he says i'm out of new york the
nick the knicks never went anyway
i don't care tru i don't care if trump
doesn't like black people
62 percent are you out of your effing
mind
now obviously the left is is having a
fit over this
but you know what leaving aside the
emojis and everything
this is a very normal very adult
reason to vote a certain way people on
the left are upset at 50 cent
and say oh you're so selfish you're so
selfish that you want to keep your own
income
what you say you don't want to work
in order to give more than half of your
income to the government so they can
squander it
you selfish bastard no normal
adults who work for a living
have responsibilities maybe have family
to take care of
we prefer to keep as much of our own
money as we can
not because we're a bunch of ebenezer
scrooges maybe we are that's our own
business
that doesn't have to be the reason it's
just that this is why we're
i don't go to work every day um
i mean if i had a real job i wouldn't go
to work every day
feeling like okay i got to do a good job
here so that i can
support the system and support the
government
no this is a normal thing
and and of course the problem is a lot
of the people on the left
especially the activists and so forth
who get upset at those of us
who want to keep our own money and who
don't want to pay
you know for example 62 percent in taxes
which which you are out of your ethic
mind to quote 50 cent
if you support that but a lot of people
don't understand this
um they don't pay anything in tax
because they don't have jobs
the activists who are out on the street
every single day it's pretty clear they
don't have jobs
so they just you know they got mommy and
daddy taking care of them
either their real mommy daddy or mommy
daddy government taking care of them
so they just don't understand how
demoralizing it is
and as i've said before i don't think
anyone even if you have a job and you
pay taxes even if you pay a lot of taxes
you still don't really understand how
bad the taxes are and how demoralizing
it really is or should be
until you've until you have
physically written checks to the
government if it's all w-2
withhold withholding you don't re you
still don't really
understand how bad it actually is so you
got to write that check
send it in watch the money leave your
bank account
okay number three disney has added
racism warnings to a number of its
classic films
um disney explains it this way this is
on their disney plus
streaming service i believe it says uh
as part of our ongoing commitment to
diversity and inclusion we are in the
process of reviewing our library and
adding
advisories to content that includes
negative depictions or mistreatment of
people or cultures
we can't change the past but we can
acknowledge it learn from it and move
forward together to create it tomorrow
that today can only hang on a second
learn from it and move forward together
to create a tomorrow
that today can only dream of
oh my good lord
this is disney we're talking about so i
guess i have to expect stuff like this
create a tomorrow that today can only
dream of
that is all right um i'll just
let that go then they go on to explain
why many of their past films are
horrifically racist and offensive
um this is what they say about peter pan
for example
and my kids love this movie so i i read
this one with interest
because i my kids love it it wasn't my
favorite growing up but my kids i've
watched it with my kids a bunch of times
i i never noticed really anything
offensive about it i never
to me it just seemed like it's it's a
story about a kid who flies around and
fights a pirate
uh but disney they'll they will tell me
why i should be offended by their own
film this is what they say
the film portrays native people in a
stereotypical manner that reflects
neither the diversity of native peoples
nor their authentic cultural traditions
it shows them that it shows them
speaking in an unintelligible language
and repeatedly refers to them as
redskins an offensive term
peter and the lost boys engage in
dancing wearing headdresses and other
exaggerated tropes
a form of mockery and appropriation of
native peoples culture and imagery
that's pretty bad yeah it's it's pretty
bad
when the magical boy who flies because
of pixie dust
is culturally appropriating you know
he should know better if he existed he
should know better
then the aristocats this is the uh
warning it says the cat is depicted as a
racist caricature of east asian peoples
with exaggerated stereotypical traits
such as slanted eyes and buck teeth he
sings in poorly accented english
by a by a voiced by a white actor and
plays the piano with chopsticks
this portrayal reinforces the perpetual
foreigner stereotype
while the film also features lyrics that
mock the chinese language and culture
such as
quote shanghai hong kong egg foo
young fortune cookie always wrong
i've never seen aristocats i might have
to check that out
swiss family robinson here's the
disclaimer there
the pirates who antagonize the robinson
family are portrayed as a stereotypical
foreign menace
many appear in quote yellow face or
brown face and are costumed in an
exaggerated
in exaggerated and inaccurate manner
with top-notch hairstyles
robes and overdone facial makeup and
jewelry reinforcing their barbarism and
otherness they speak in an
indecipherable language presenting a
singular and racist representation
of asian and middle eastern peoples okay
well you know that one's
really important too because you have to
make sure that uh you
portray pirates with sensitivity you'll
be very sensitive
to the pirates when you're portraying
them and they are a sensitive bunch
and so that's essential um
what does it really say about this it's
obviously ludicrous and embarrassing for
disney
but if disney here's really my point if
disney
had the courage of its convictions it
would just get rid of these movies
it would take them out of circulation
destroy them
uh save our children from being
corrupted by the racism and
bigotry because most kids who watch
peter pan anyway
probably can't read the disclaimer and
so now you're relying on parents to read
it for them and i can tell you
as as a parent i'm not going to read the
disclaimer to my kids i'm sorry i'm just
not going to read it
if they ask me daddy what does that say
i'll say i don't worry about it just
something stupid don't worry
and if i do read it i'll probably i
won't be able to help myself from
laughing while i read it
and that's going to send the wrong
message so my point is don't put the
ball in my court as a parent
you should just get rid of the movies
don't stream them
don't sell them on dvd or anything
um not merchandise get rid of all that
but they don't want to do that why is
that
if you've noticed they could they could
take that approach
that would really send the best message
and again if these are
really racist horrible movies then why
are you choosing to you're choosing to
stream them on your own platform while
you apologize
i'm so sorry for this i'm so sorry that
i'm showing you this right now as i show
it to you i'm so sorry
please forgive me while i continue doing
this thing right now that i can stop
doing
but they don't want to do that because
they make a lot of money uh they make
they make a lot of money from from some
of these properties i don't know how
much they make from aristocats but
they make a lot of money from peter pan
i'm sure um especially the
the merchandise and the the the the
peter pan
property and brand and all of that so
they want to they want the money
but they still want the wokeness so this
is just performative
fake wokeness which is all which is the
only kind of wokeness we ever get
anymore of course
number four uh rush limbo limbaugh on
his show on
on monday had an update on his battle
with
lung cancer it wasn't a good update but
i thought i thought um his
whole segment on it was pretty powerful
i can't play the whole thing because
several minutes long but
let me play just part of it what listen
to this from the moment you get the
diagnosis
there's a part of you every day okay
that's it life's over
you just don't know when but when you
get that diagnosis i mean that's
so during
the period of time after the diagnosis
you do what you can to prolong
life you do what you can to prolong a
happy
life you measure a happy life
against whatever medication it takes and
at
some point do you decide you know this
medication may be working but i
hate the way i feel over this is this
i'm not
there yet but but but it is
part and parcel of this it's
it's it's tough to realize that the days
where i
do not think i'm under a death sentence
are over now we all
are is the point we all
know that we're going to die at some
point but
when you have a terminal disease
diagnosis
that has a time frame to it then that
puts a different
a different psychological and and even
physical
awareness to it we are all under
a death sentence he says and that's
that's true that's a profound truth
one that i think most of us simply
refuse to accept
um certainly we don't want to think
about it we don't want to face the
implications
but rush limbaugh here is staring into
the abyss facing down his own mortality
his own death
and doing it with courage and dignity
and you know the leftist critics of his
uh excitedly preparing to dance on his
grave
reveling in his suffering and i'm sure
you've seen if you go online and you
really want to see this sort of thing
you can go find it i don't know why
you'd want to see it but you can
um but all the ones doing that
we know that most of them will not have
the strength to confront their
death their impending death the way that
rush is confronting his
and that's what makes it so stupid by
the way so stupid to delight in another
person's death
or eventual death i mean obviously what
the people are doing with rush limbaugh
is also evil
and vile and disgusting and grotesque
from a moral standpoint but
i'm talking even aside from the morality
of it it's stupid because
what do you think you're going to live
forever you don't think this is going to
happen to you
you will also be dead very soon
relatively speaking
you're what you're doing when you
delight in someone else's death and
suffering
you are essentially pointing and
laughing at someone
while they walk down a road that you are
also walking on
or maybe maybe a better analogy you're
on the same train as them
heading over the same cliff and laughing
as their train car goes over the edge
well you're in a train car just a few
cars back
your time is coming in mere moments
relatively speaking you're going where
they're going you're under the same
sentence as he points out
so it's but i but i think
it it is it is in recognition of that
that's one of the reasons why people
react this way to the death sometimes to
death and especially
the deaths of people they don't like uh
it's a defense mechanism
it's a way of sort of convincing
themselves or pretending that this is
never going to happen to them
that death is somehow this sort of like
absurd abstract
far-off thing and something that only
happens to people they don't like
but that's not true and they'll get a
wake-up call um
but anyway a lot of dignity and courage
from rush limbaugh so god bless
god bless him um number five finally
we talked about dignity let's go to the
other end of the spectrum
uh headline in the wall street journal
says
men's nail polish is taking off why now
uh and then the the subheading says
influenced by celebrities like
bad bunny harry styles and aesop rocky
i only know who one of those people are
harry styles is uh
who's what's he from he's a singer right
i sort of know him i don't know
bad bunny it there's a male celebrity
who goes by
bad bunny um anyway it says young guys
nationwide are turning to nail polish
and companies are meeting the demand
with muted male
shades now i can't read the article
because it's behind the paywall and i'm
not going to pay for this kind of
content but
uh i don't really need to read it i can
simply answer
the question being posed in the in the
headline and by saying uh
it's it's not happening you're asking
why it's happening now it's not
it's not taking off this is what we call
an attempt at a self-fulfilling prophecy
and the media does this all the time all
the time especially when it comes to
masculinity and those sorts of things
they're always finding these absurd
effeminate
styles that like two guys are wearing
and they put out these headlines and
saying men everywhere doing this
look men everywhere are wearing lipstick
and yoga pants
how did this style take off no it didn't
you just want it to you freaks that's
the difference
um okay another seamless transition
because speaking of freaks we'll talk
about um
something related to that just a second
in a daily cancellation but before we do
you know as with everything in 2020
there's been a lot of drama with the
presidential debates we already talked
about that but we're ready for the next
and final debate this thursday join us
at 8 45
p.m eastern 5 45 p.m pacific for an all
all-new episode of daily wire backstage
to watch the debate with us
and get our immediate live reaction to
this major political event and even
better
join daily wire now as an insider or all
access member get 20
off with code debate so you can watch
all the debate coverage live on our
apple tv or roku app
um members get our articles ad free
access to our live broadcast the full
three hours of the bench piro show
a lot of great benefits you can also
watch daily wire backstage so watch the
debate with us on dailywire.com youtube
and facebook and get 20
uh 20 off your daily wire membership
with code debate
when you sign up today okay time for our
daily
cancellation for our daily cancellation
today sort of a sequel to yesterday's
cancellation which i
destroyed phone calls with facts and
logic i explained
on the show on monday that nobody is
allowed to talk on the phone anymore
phone calls are officially canceled
and i gave my reasons which i won't
rehash here but
in response to that segment there were a
number of people who suggested that
perhaps video calling of some kind skype
facetime zoom etc
would be a way around this cancellation
yes phone calls are canceled but
when you can see the other person's face
it isn't technically a phone call
so shouldn't it be exempt the answer is
no
and also stop trying to play fast and
loose with the rules
you are expected to obey both the
letters of my commands
when it comes to the cancellations but
also the spirit of the law
as well as any arbitrary exceptions or
addendums i might come up with
and as if in a concerted effort to prove
my point or or perhaps as an as an
indication that my cancellations also
have the power of prophecy
a news story broke shortly after my show
yesterday demonstrating
the dangers of all forms of phone or
related audible communication and also
demonstrating why video chat
cannot be an exception and for that we
turn to
new yorker writer and cnn contributor
jeffrey toobin who has been suspended by
the new yorker after
reportedly exposing his genitals during
a zoom call with co-workers
and um actually it's reported i'm afraid
to say he was uh well
engaging with himself uh in an intimate
fashion
if you catch my drift right there on on
zoom
now um many questions present themselves
here so
you know just as tubing apparently
presented himself
uh questions such as what
and but why and
seriously bro perhaps the details of the
case as reported by vice will
satisfy some of these inquiries just as
tubin was
well never mind uh vice reports two
people who were on the call told vice
separately that
the call was an election simulation
featuring many of the new yorker's
biggest stars jane meyer was playing
establishment republicans evan
osnos was joe biden jelani cobb was
establishment democrats
masha gessen played donald trump andrew
merence was the far right
sue halpern was left-wing democrats
dexter filkins
was the military and was the military
and
jeffrey toobin playing the courts dexter
filkins was the military well
uh now let me step to the side to say
that actually i have no clue what the
hell any of that
means they were they were play acting
the election on zoom
why is this what new yorker staff does
for fun
it wouldn't surprise me i suppose though
tubin would seem to have taken the role
play in an unexpectedly
sexual direction uh vice has more says
both people who spoke on the condition
of anonymity in order to speak freely
noted that
it was unclear how much each person saw
but both said that they saw tuban
pleasuring himself the sources said that
when the groups returned from their
breakout rooms
tubin lowered the camera the people on
the call said they could see tubin
compromised tube and then left the call
moments later he called back in
seemingly unaware of what his colleagues
had been able to see
and the simulation continued the
simulation continued they just charged
right along as if they hadn't just seen
jeffrey toobin's tube you have to
respect that in a certain way
um but the truth is you can kind of see
jeffrey tuban's point
i mean you can literally see it but
that's not that's not what i'm trying to
say
tubin says that he didn't know the
camera was on
which is an explanation that leaves
quite a lot to still be explained
even so it's also true that if not for
video calling
none of this would have happened or it
probably would have happened but nobody
would have seen it
this brings to mind the old riddle if
jeffrey tubin touches himself in the
forest and no one is there to see it
did it really happen answer yes but no
psychological damage was caused to any
unwilling spectators
and that's really what we're trying to
prevent here
look let's get away from jeffrey toobin
for a moment mercifully
the fact is that video calling and
video conferencing itself presents all
kinds of potential pitfalls
even if they're less pornographic in
nature it could put you in a difficult
spot when someone insists
randomly on speaking to you in a in a
virtual face-to-face setting
inevitably if you're at home you haven't
combed your hair you haven't showered
since last tuesday
now all of a sudden you have to put
minimal effort into your appearance when
the whole point of being home is that
you don't have to do that
it's an intrusion an imposition but most
of all a la jeffrey toobin
it forces me to see you and whatever you
might be doing
the person who initiates the video call
format is a narcissist who's basically
saying
hey would it be really great right now
if you could see my face
the answer is no it wouldn't and in a
professional setting in particular i can
say that nothing has ever been achieved
on a zoom
conference that couldn't have been
achieved in 15 minutes through a group
email
one last point here and this is
important this is perhaps the most
significant problem with especially
facetime and skype
uh people have decided apparently that
because it's a video call
it's okay to do it in public now
most people know that you shouldn't sit
in a coffee shop and speak to another
person on speakerphone some people still
do that
sociopaths but for some reason
if the speaker has a video component
suddenly it's assumed the rules have
changed they haven't
i shouldn't have to hear your discussion
with another human being
if that human being is not physically in
the room with you
especially if they aren't wearing pants
and that's why see if you think i would
just cancel jeffrey tuban i'm not
i'm can't well him too although i don't
think i need to cancel it's a bit
redundant at this point
uh really i'm canceling zoom and video
calling all of that
and this just brings us back to where we
were yesterday what what what are we
left with
no no phone calling no video calling no
video conferencing fine
you got text message you got email and
you also have
good old-fashioned snail mail okay
if the if the new yorker staff if they
had conducted their
election simulation through some sort of
paypal system
or rather a pen pal system sending
letters back and forth um
across enemy lines then then certainly
this wouldn't have happened
and that's why all of that is canceled
all right
we'll leave it there thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
the director of national intelligence
confirms that the hunter biden emails
are
real a cnn analyst gets caught with his
pants down
and more evidence of voter fraud crops
up in kentucky
check it out on the michael knowles show